pedigree is the name of the book how
elite students get elite jobs
northwestern university professor lauren
rivera is the author
professor rivera how do you define elite
it's an excellent question i think it
depends who you ask so i've been looking
at elite jobs in terms of investment
banking management consulting firms and
law firms and these are in many ways the
business the i call them the baby
business elite
they are very very prestigious positions
also those that involve high levels of
economic rewards in terms of salaries
there are other types of elites they're
cultural elites they're media elites but
i'm really looking at business elites so
these are just the people who are in the
most prestigious and rewarding segments
does elite beget elite
i think it does for better if for worse
why um i think that there are some
conscious processes at play a lot of it
is unconscious too i think that we as
humans naturally gravitate towards
people who are similar to ourselves and
when it comes to
elites whether they're economic elites
or cultural elites there are certain
ways of being carrying yourself
educational tracks and so forth
that are more common among people in a
certain social strata and we come to
believe that that's the best one and
that's what people who have merit
what they the types of paths they pursue
so it reminds me of the psychological
research that shows that when you ask
someone what kind of driver is a good
driver or what kind of parent is a good
parent they'll describe someone exactly
like themselves and i think that there's
something going on there in terms of
when you ask people who are in positions
of power in society
what merit is they'll give it a
definition that is strikingly similar to
whatever they are it's true in other
segments of society as well we have
these similar to me type biases but it's
definitely one thing that contributes
all right walk us through a case study
of how an elite student
gets an elite job yes so in general the
types of occupations i'm studying
getting an entry-level job straight out
of undergrad straight out of business
school or law school in an elite
professional service firm so top
management consulting firm top
investment bank top law school the
biggest key is to go to the right
schools these firms have a very very
strict view that the best and the
brightest only go to top schools and
they have a very definition a narrow
definition of what a top school is so as
a sociologist i might think a top 50
school is an elite school or selective
school that's not what the the game is
here the game here is to be at a top
five top 10 university
so that's the first key the second is
that you need to have the right resume
to get in the door for undergraduates
this is the most fuzzy because a lot of
undergraduates don't have a lot of work
experience they may have one or two
internships under their belt but the
more prestigious the internship the
better
these employers often aren't necessarily
looking for having concrete skills in a
given domain if you go to princeton if
you go to harvard if you go to columbia
they trust that you're smart enough to
do the job and they can teach you
whatever you want have to learn so they
look for internships often that are
unpaid that's one of the class
dimensions of this
as well as extracurricular profiles that
are filled with activities that are
motivated by personal passion things
like sports
depending on the inner person who
screens your resume
drama can be a good one if you happen to
have an athlete screening a resume and
you're heavily involved in drama you may
be out of luck but this idea that
people who the best and the brightest
cultivate their their skills their
intellect not only in the classroom but
outside of it is huge so if you don't
have extracurricular activities that are
intense pers and are motivated by
passion you're out of the game that's
getting into the interview room do you
want me to continue
so if you're selected to interview
a lot of the interviews are open-ended
so the interviewer will sit down just
like we did and in have an open-ended
conversation for the first five or so
minutes
why are you here what do you like to do
in your spare time and a feeling of
personal chemistry often based on
similarity in things in terms of things
that are outside of work outside of
school are a huge source of interview
success
after that some firms will
have some sort of skills test in
consulting it's the most structured you
do what's called a case interview and i
can tell you more about that if you're
interested but the idea is you're
supposed to
speak to your interviewer in a way where
you are equals
throughout the interview that you're
supposed to foster a feeling of
chemistry and all of these things
success is partly dependent upon having
a baseline familiarity with upper middle
class and upper class culture
you say in your book that a structured
interview benefits
the non-elites more than the elites is
that what do you mean for the most part
so structured interviews let me start
with unstructured interviews
unstructured interviews are the most
common interviews that american hiring
managers use they love them because it
allows your personal theory of success
to to be the guiding force you may think
that what really drives success in life
and in your job is the fact that you're
from a certain state or that you come
from a certain family background and
with an unstructured interview it really
is about the conversation and whatever
you personally think
drives success that is
used to measure interview performance a
structured interview is when you ask the
same questions to all of the interview
candidates ideally those are informed by
analyses of what types of factors
actually predict on the job's success so
i may think coming from iowa is a good
predictor of
on-the-job success for a given job but
that may have nothing to do with it if
you actually crunch the numbers so
structured interviews
ideally have data-driven structured
assessments whereby the candidate is
asked to do something job relevant the
reason and in general those tend to
reduce inequality because they put a
tamper on the personal biases that we
have
and our
elect keeps interviewers more
focusing on job relevant criteria
when interviews are unstructured
physical attractiveness race all these
things can can
run run crazy in interviewers
evaluations the one downside to having a
highly structured interview process and
i talk about this in the book a little
bit with consulting case interviews is
that if for some reason whatever
structure you've adopted let's say in
consulting they have these case
interviews where applicants are asked to
solve a business problem similar to one
that they might encounter on the job
and they have to go through
this very stylized script where if you
don't know the rules of this particular
type of interview interaction you're not
going to do well and in that setting
when a structured interview requires
mastery of insider codes that require
knowing an insider to to get ahead it
may not level the playing field
professor rivera you write wes
a law student from a working class
family
talked about recruiting events quote i
would generally stand over in the corner
with my friends or stand on by the bar
and then just get drunk so i didn't
really use that as a recruiting tool
maybe that would have been smart but i
felt like a tool bag i hate like
schmoozing when you go to cocktail
parties
i think that
the knowledge
what counts and what doesn't count in
the interview process
depends a lot on your connections and
your connections are influenced by your
background i also think that the knowing
that networking and schmoozing and even
chemistry in a job interview can carry
the day is a type of class-based
cultural knowledge that not everyone has
often working class students enter the
classroom enter universities enter
interviews with the opinion that what's
on their resume counts most and in
especially an elite job that's simply
not the case the networking is a huge
part of it and not only knowing that
you're supposed to do it but doing it
well can make or break a candidate
what do you teach here at northwestern
professor i teach leadership
what is the downside of
pedigree of elite students getting elite
jobs is there a downside i think that
there can be i think that one is that we
like to live in a society where at least
we believe that opportunity is at least
in theory open and when there are
processes in place like the ones i
document in the book that systematically
make it such that if you don't come from
one of these backgrounds your chances of
getting a top paying job are very small
it's not impossible it's just very very
difficult that threatens our our notion
of the american dream and
our being an open society but i think
for firms i think the most worrying part
is that there's some evidence to suggest
that students from the highest class
backgrounds as well as the most elite
schools really tend not to like these
jobs these jobs are really really
difficult they require lots of hours on
the job lots of mundane tasks and a lot
of people find them really really rough
but there's evidence to suggest that
elite students are and whether it's
class background or educational
background are actually worse fits for
the job than individuals for more modest
economic means or from less prestigious
schools so people who come from the
elite backgrounds tend to want to leave
these jobs earlier usually within the
one first one to two years of entering
before they've been there long enough to
pay back recruiting costs whereas some
of these jobs are meant as temporary
positions they're not necessarily meant
to take you all the way to partnership
but students from less elite backgrounds
tend to actually like the work more and
want to stay longer there's also some
research to suggest that individuals
from lower class backgrounds actually
have better
coping skills listening skills things
that are all asset and very demanding
client facing professions
are schools
guilty as well of
perpetuating this elite
system i think they are i don't
necessarily think it's intentional
i think that especially elite
universities have some pretty strong
incentives to keep this going
one is the fact that national rankings
especially for business and law schools
directly factor in starting salaries for
recent graduates into the rankings
so there is a and rankings have become
so important for universities both in
terms of their own status but in terms
of alumni donations things they can get
on
that can happen down the line so sending
as many students as possible to the
highest paying jobs benefits elite
universities
i think the second way that universities
are complicit is that the most elite
universities especially undergraduate
business school and law school is very
very top-ranked
they
allow these firms almost unfettered
access to their students and what that
does
is it creates a climate on campus where
these careers end up being a crucial
marker of self-worth for a lot of
students and so people end up going into
these careers probably in much greater
numbers than they would otherwise
because
the recruiting process that has been
described as literally taking over
campuses
for several months per year has made it
such that these are the most visible and
high status jobs available to students
we're sitting here at northwestern
university you teach at the kellogg
school of management yep your top five
aren't you we are we are and we send a
lot of our students to management
consulting and i'm a former management
consultant myself
but um yeah i think that universities
are
play a big role in this
how do you how do you fight this
i think that it requires two things the
first actually has to do with
universities one of the big reasons why
the playing field for elite jobs is so
skewed happens to be that universities
elite universities at both the
undergraduate and the graduate level
tend to use highly class biased
admission criteria
so the when you look at the student
population of a very top school whether
again it's at the undergraduate or in
business and law at the graduate level
these
programs tend to be dominated by
students from the most affluent
households so you're skewing the
population
to begin with
but when you look at firms that will
only recruit from those schools if they
have a class biased population from
which to recruit
their hiring practices are naturally
going to be class biased but then if you
add on top of that class biased hiring
practices like these firms have
privileging things like not only
school prestige but other things that
are correlated with socioeconomic status
of the applicant's parents such as
participation in high status
extracurricular activities unpaid
internship these very class-based
notions of polish and what it means to
be a well-spoken person
inside knowledge of the interview
process and so forth you result in what
you get is a system where there's a
double filter on socioeconomic status
does this lead to a racial bias at all
the racial biases are
part of the process so i think it's
important to disentangle race and
socioeconomic status because they are
very different and i think that this
hiring process has really strongly
disadvantaged students from low-income
backgrounds regardless of their race in
addition what happens in some of the
interviews
and some of the deliberations among
hiring committees is that people use
stereotypes as shortcuts to judge
candidates and especially with
african-american men there is a racial
stereotype that employers operate on
that people are less polished so you see
and it's very very clear that if an
applicant falters just a little bit
who's an african-american male on
something related to interpersonal
communication this triggers this larger
stereotype they're out of the pool i
watched how equivalent otherwise
equivalent applicants who were white men
who would make the exact same error and
they were kept in they were considered
to be coachable so i think that there
are subtle racial biases that happen
throughout this process but also in
addition to it
that that also create racial biases in
this process the other thing is is that
the schools from which these firms
recruit tend not to be the most racially
diverse schools to begin with so you
have the pipeline issue but then you
also again have the bias issue in terms
of what employers are doing to to
reinforce the inequalities we have in
society today professor rivera former
management consultant rivera
are you part of this elite system have
you been guilty of this yourself or
not trying to put you on the spot here
i'm just curious yeah i mean i never did
interviews from my old firm
but i've lived in this world for a long
time and
i think that
it is quite tempting to take a lot of
the shortcuts that these firms take and
that we take as humans in terms of you
like people more who are similar to you
if someone comes from a shared
background it's easier to relate to them
i think we're all guilty of that so i
don't think i'm i'm unique in that i
don't necessarily have any authority to
hire anyone so
you know not yet at least and i hope
that when i am in a position i'll put in
structured
protocols that will hopefully result in
a more fair is pedigree written for
management students is it written for
the general public it's written
primarily for sociologists actually
i got my phd in sociology and the impact
is really
intended to be for for scholars who are
interested in issues of inequality
if it has
also impacts for managers and
practitioners as well as mba students
i'm very very happy about that but the
intended audience was
was really sociologists but again with
any book it's really nice that anyone
reads it so if it gathers more public
appeal that's that's great too and
princeton press has put this book out
you use the word polished yep quite a
bit in this book yes what does it mean
to be polished so polish is what my
interviewees would talk about as they
use it interchangeably with presence and
communication skills these are soft
skills can you interact with a client
are you presentable
to a team to
to someone who's an executive and i
think that the definition of polish
varies from place to place if you look
at an advertising agency the type of
mannerisms and the type of behaviors
that are valued might be different from
an elite law firm likewise in academia
we have very different styles of
self-presentation than in the corporate
world but in this world it means a
couple of things it means being formal
without being too formal so having a
sense of relax of relaxation between you
and the person you're talking with
that's one of the reasons why a lot of
the black candidates are actually thrown
out as they're perceived to either be
too formal or too informal and that's a
judgment that happens through this lens
of racial stereotypes but so the first
thing is being
formal enough to be professional but not
too informal to be
immature the second which is really
important is in the interview context
taking the reins of the conversation so
a lot of people may think that in an
interview you're supposed to just
passively answer the questions the
interviewer asks you that's how you
would do an interview in many many many
different types of of occupations but
here it's called conversational
leadership taking the reins of
conversation the idea is that you're
trying to treat the interviewer as an
equal so rather than having them be you
have the position of power and you're
the person who wants the job you want to
create this into a conversation of
equals and there's a sociologist named
seamus khan who's at columbia who talks
about how that is a hallmark of economic
elites the ability to make anyone feel
at ease regardless of how
how high or how low they are
in term relative to you in the economic
hierarchy that sense of ease is
important and that is absolutely
essential and that type of communication
skill is different than if you went to
interview at say you wanted a job at a
factory if you tried to find
commonalities and create this sense of
equality your interviewer would not be
pleased
lauren rivera
if you don't go to an elite school
community college or a local local
campus
are there two strikes against you at
that point if you're going to a
community college and their chances are
you're not going to get through the door
if you are at a four-year university
that happens to be a non-elite
university say a public university
that's not a flagship or in some cases
some firms have a very very narrow
conception of elite and even a public
flagship would not be
prestigious enough for them the the key
there is to have a connection someone
inside a firm who can pass on your
resume and get you a look otherwise
these firms have so many applicants from
schools that they consider to be good
schools
and those are their words not mine i
think a lot of wonderful schools
in the country that are not on these
firms lists but
but unless you can get someone
get someone's attention through a
connection you're out
here's the book pedigree how elite
students get elite jobs
northwestern professor lauren rivera is
the author
is there a non-fiction author or book
you'd like to see featured on book tv
send us an email to booktv cspan.org
tweet us at booktv